[Musique]
c'est à l'entrée de cette enseigne de
bricolage que le département lohan n'est
fait les représentants des trois
magasins leroy merlin inaugurent
l'exposition à travers mille et un
regard ce qui est important c'est que le
grand public puisse comprendre que la
forêt là le milieu naturel de la réunion
c'est un milieu qui est grandiose qui
semble fort mais qui est fragile et il
est nécessaire que l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens de la réunion puisse
protéger ces milieux qui sont des
milieux d'exception pour le monde entier
comprendre les missions de la forêt le
réchauffement climatique ou encore la
préservation de la biodiversité
à l'instar d'une action nationale
enseigne accompagne localement les
acteurs de la forêt très content parce
que c'est historique c'est une histoire
l'histoire de la famille à rabat de bouc
puis mon père qui à l'époque allait dans
les forêts tamarins
chercher le bois bois de construction
matériaux de construction et tout est
aujourd'hui aussi une convention pour
leurs voisins de cette forêt de tamarins
avec un partenaire qui est le
département et le nf
cette convention va notamment permettre
la reforestation de parcelles de tamarin
des hauts par un mécénat en faveur du
fonds agir pour la forêt et ainsi
contribuer à l'action un million
d'arbres pour la réunion tous ces
partenaires permettent d'accompagner la
sensibilisation et la protection de la
nature réunionnaise
[Musique]